well here with reaction Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz and Michael best
slaw president former White House chief
of staff for President Trump Wright's
previous let's start with the show the
circus
the compromised corrupt congenital liar
Matt Gaetz and what they tell everybody
how corrupt tomorrow is especially
compared to how Republicans treated Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton's lawyers and the
minority party in 1998 it's obvious to
the American people that Democrats can't
win a fair fight because the president
did not engage in any impeachable
offense
and so you see Democrats doing
everything they can to limit our ability
to call witnesses limit our ability to
yield time to members who've been in the
depositions but all of the dirty tricks
from Adam shifts bag of tricks will not
change a few fundamental facts first
then we can see the transcript and there
is no conditionality on any aid second
that President Trump and President
szalinski the actual people on the call
so there was no pressure third at the
time of the call the Ukrainians were not
aware of any delay on their aid
whatsoever and fourth and finally the
aid that Barack Obama withheld was
delivered by the Trump administration
without any beginning of any
investigations into Maurice MA or hunter
Biden now I think that the Democrats
will try to do all they can to have
conjecture around those facts but
nothing changes them and that means
there shouldn't be an impeachment you
know right it's kind of amazing and I'm
my last Lindsey Graham this in a little
bit but they've actually made the this
guy who was compromised this guy was a
fact witness in this case this guy
already he by the way he lied about the
transcript so then when he actually was
reading he actually made up a fake
transcript and then he'll oh I wish we
did have contact with the whistleblower
he was lying about that he's like but
three years about Russia how is it the
Democrats are dumb enough to pick that
compromised guy fact witness to be their
leader in this well it's created another
environment here Sean that's created the
environment of total partisanship and as
long as there's total partisanship to
300,000 people out there in the
battleground states that need to decide
this thing
are gonna look at it just as some
political game that's led by a political
person like Adam Schiff now Matt Gaetz
nailed it and by the way he did a great
job by blowing up the Star Chamber a
couple weeks ago in exposing all of this
but I think it's really important to do
it what congressman gates just did and
narrow this down to exactly what it is
on its worst day for the president you
have a a non consummated wrongdoing I'm
at worse so what do you have you have
the money was released which which it
was so number so finally what do we have
that's on trial what we have on trial is
the state of mind of the president
because there was no consummated action
because the money was released so the
American people are now watching in the
money but and the money was really so
because now you have a trial on the
state of mind of the president you have
to allow that state of mind to be in
focus which means you have to bring the
Biden issue in the play you have to
bring the corruption in the play and let
all of that play out but as congressman
gates said if you don't have the
authority to call the witnesses like
hunter Biden and Joe Biden to the stand
and say what was really going on in
Ukraine because it's relevant to the
president's state of mind then you don't
have a face a trial that was one of the
best that analysis I've ever seen what
is your how look you know Wisconsin
better than anybody how will the P the
300,000 in those six states that you
mentioned reacted this this witch-hunt
no due process show put on by this
corrupt compromise wire in this case if
the president wins either Wisconsin or
Michigan or Pennsylvania one of the
three he gets reelected in Wisconsin
this impeachment trials not playing out
well at all in fact you can go look at
the Marquette poll of 10 days ago and it
showed only 41 percent of the people in
Wisconsin support this impeachment trial
only 41% there's not 41 percent support
for Trump but yet 41 percent of the
people say this is this is a 49% say
this
- garbage let's check it out tell us how
this is gonna play out Matt well if we
are not able to get hunter Biden before
the House committees I hope that your
upcoming guest senator Graham will bring
him before the Senate right alongside
the whistle blower that'll really blow
the top off this entire scam
all right the circus is coming to town
got elephants we got crazy people
everywhere all right thank you both